I mean how do you know when you're ready
is sort of a big question with free
selling and I think ultimately you just
you just know
[Music]
I found out about it last night my
girlfriend called me around 10 o'clock
so I left work immediately if anyone
asks I was at a doctor's appointment
I mean it was kind of freaky at first
like not until you look down you realize
like oh wow this is real and now
concerned you're watching Alex go
through stuff that like I wouldn't even
touch
I felt like I was up there with him it
was it was beautiful to be able to just
turn around and see like just the views
that he has behind him around him it was
awesome
[Music]
oh my God good how are you he made it
what happened look over here oh Jesus
Christ
oh my gosh well we want to invite you to
the premiere on Thursday the red carpet
yeah
well I had no idea it was gonna be such
a good day when I woke up this morning
[Music]
the film was phenomenal like the
cinematography was beautiful like the
whole relationship thing was just like
completely different from what I
expected going in and it just made me
feel a lot of things it was wonderful
all together
I thought it was amazing it was truly
inspiring and
I really want to go climb right now
hard to put into words but it felt so
much more relatable this guy that I
looked up to and thought that the robot
is a human
[Music]
I am
I am for the world right now I'm shaking
I'm never gonna forget this night this
is one of the most incredible evenings
of my entire life